[Aplausos]
[Música]
el comienzo del año 2020 en china ha
sido más tormentoso que la relación
entre iker casillas y jose mourinho a
las noticias sobre la desaceleración
económica que han conducido al país a
registrar el menor crecimiento económico
ni más ni menos que desde el año 1990
que se le ha sumado el terrible impacto
de el coronavirus acontecimientos que
por supuesto seguiremos y de los que
podéis estar seguros os daremos todos
los detalles aquí en visual político sin
embargo en esta ocasión os vamos a
hablar de otra de las grandes amenazas a
las que se enfrenta el gigante chino una
amenaza que puede cambiar por completo
las expectativas que muchos tenéis sobre
la evolución geopolítica de este país
habéis escuchado hablar de la política
del hijo único
pues amigos ahora esa política que en su
día se vendió como una acción
indispensable vital ineludible para
alcanzar el desarrollo se ha dado la
vuelta y se ha convertido en todo un
cuchillo que amenaza incluso el papel de
china como superpotencia mundial para
que un país mantenga su población sin
tener en cuenta los movimientos
migratorios es necesaria una tasa de
fertilidad de al menos 2,1 hijos por
mujer es lo que se conoce como tasa de
reemplazo en la actualidad sin embargo
las mujeres chinas tienen 1,6 hijos por
mujer y la tasa de natalidad ha caído
unos 20 nacimientos por cada mil
habitantes en 1990 a poco más de 10 en
2019 o con otras palabras los chinos
tienen la mitad de hijos hoy que hace
tan solo 20 años
amigos todo esto os puede parecer a
simple vista algo poco importante sin
embargo lo cierto es que sus
consecuencias pueden llegar a ser
enormes especialmente en el campo de la
geopolítica internacional es por eso que
en el 2015 el gobierno chino puso punto
y final a la política del hijo único y
ahora ahora buscan niños como el agua de
mayo
[Música]
pero qué está pasando realmente qué
ocurrió con la política del hijo único
porque ahora todo se ha dado la vuelta y
qué tiene que ver todo esto con el
futuro de china atentos
[Música]
el gran error demográfico
y amigos cada vez que los políticos
juegan a diseñar moldear y construir
sociedades a su antojo es carne de cañón
para visual político los resultados
suelen ser nefastos ya sabéis eso de que
el papel lo aguanta todo
pues algo así es lo que ocurrió en china
la política del hijo único pasó de ser
un alivio a convertirse en toda una
pesada carga
[Música]
pero para entender realmente en qué
consiste el problema tenemos que
remontarnos hasta mediados del siglo 20
en ese momento el gigante asiático aún
no había completado su transición
demográfica es decir para que nos
entendamos las mujeres aún tenían muchos
hijos para compensar tasas de mortalidad
también muy elevadas
básicamente el escenario propio de
cualquier sociedad pre industrial las
tasas de mortalidad se reducen mucho más
rápido que las tasas de natalidad lo que
provoca un enorme crecimiento de la
población
y es que es precisamente ese gap esa
diferencia entre la caída de la
natalidad que lo hace lentamente y la
caída de la mortalidad lo que explica
los grandes cambios demográficos del
último siglo y es por ejemplo lo que
ahora está ocurriendo en áfrica
sin embargo amigos en el caso de china
hubo algo más el gobierno de mao
promovía activamente la natalidad la
idea fundamental era algo así como que
la mano de obra disponible era lo que
causaba el crecimiento económico de tal
forma que cuanta más mano de obra
tuviese el país más desarrollo
conseguiría este
[Música]
una buena prueba de este espíritu la
tenemos a comienzos de la década de los
60 cuando se produjo la gran hambruna
que le costó la vida a más de 15
millones de personas como consecuencia
del conocido como gran salto adelante el
segundo plan quinquenal de mao tse tung
del que ya os hemos hablado en algún que
otro vídeo tras semejante catástrofe
demográfica el objetivo del gobierno fue
promover la natalidad a toda costa
[Música]
y el caso es que entre unas cosas y
otras en apenas 30 años la población se
disparó en casi 400 millones de personas
y fue exactamente ahí cuando los líderes
comunistas pensaron que todo esto de la
natalidad se les había ido de las manos
y que de continuar con semejante
crecimiento demográfico china nunca
conseguiría alcanzar el desarrollo
porque la población crecía tanto más que
los recursos necesarios para mantenerla
por eso en 1979 el gobierno chino
decidió dar un golpe en la mesa y decir
vale hasta aquí hemos llegado tenemos
chinos por encima de nuestras
posibilidades así que ahora quieto todo
el mundo un hijo es suficiente y como
tengas más te vas a enterar y así fue
como llegó la política del hijo único
que permaneció en vigor hasta el año
2015 únicamente en algunas zonas rurales
y casos concretos se permitía tener más
de un hijo en el resto pues no y amigos
hablamos de una política que por
supuesto tuvo consecuencias inesperadas
se calcula que durante el tiempo que
estuvo en vigor la política de hijo
único se terminó con la vida de más de
360 millones de fetos y niños ya nacidos
la causa por un lado evitar las
sanciones que imponía el gobierno por
incumplir la ley y por otro la
preferencia que existió en china de
tener hijos varones sobre mujeres
de hecho este último fenómeno está
última salvajada hizo que en algunas
regiones chinas llegase a haber 125
hombres por cada 100 mujeres la ratio
más desigual del planeta
[Música]
en fin barbaridades que por supuesto han
sido duramente criticadas por las
organizaciones de derechos humanos y es
que amigos la política del hijo único se
convirtió en la operación de ingeniería
social más grande y masiva que jamás se
haya llevado a cabo
y tal y como os podéis imaginar tras
casi cuatro décadas de implantación
estricta de esta política las
consecuencias son enormes han dejado
mella en la estructura social del país
fijaos
[Música]
china ya no le salen los números
y los expertos lo tienen claro china
debería haber acabado con la política
hace 28 años ahora es demasiado tarde y
fucsia investigador en la universidad de
wisconsin pero porque afirma este buen
señor que es demasiado tarde tarde para
que pues amigos fijaos en el siguiente
gráfico
no
luego que podéis ver es simple y
llanamente un cambio radical en la
estructura demográfica china un cambio
radical que comienza con una pérdida
abrumadora de población ese es el
escenario que se va enfrentar este país
durante las próximas décadas
mientras el número de niños menores de
14 años va a caer considerablemente la
población mayor de 65 va a crecer de
forma salvaje durante las próximas
décadas y no sólo eso lo que es aún peor
se espera que la población en edad de
trabajar se reduzca paulatinamente en
cerca de 200 millones de personas 200
millones durante los próximos 30 años
[Música]
y de ahí al finales del siglo la cosa
puede ser mucho peor de hecho de acuerdo
con la propia oficina nacional de
estadística de china la población en
edad de trabajar comenzó a reducirse
desde el año 2012 y tan solo en 2019 se
contrajo en casi 900.000 personas para
que os hagáis una idea así es como está
cambiando la pirámide demográfica
es algo parecido a lo que va a ocurrir
en países como singapur japón o corea
del sur con una diferencia china se va a
enfrentar a este problema cuando aún no
es un país desarrollado
y claro con una población trabajadora
menguante y cada vez más población
dependiente pues los problemas no tardan
en aparecer fondos de pensiones estatal
de china se agotará para 2035 al
hundirse la fuerza laboral por los
efectos de la política del hijo único
según un estudio y ahí no terminan todos
los problemas todos los parámetros de la
economía pueden verse afectados por
ejemplo hasta ahora gran parte del
crecimiento económico de china ha
procedido de la incorporación de más y
más y más trabajadores a la economía
productiva sin embargo ahora eso está
cambiando y son muchos los analistas que
apuntan a este hecho como una de las
causas de su desaceleración económica
[Música]
para colmo china es un país que está en
vías de desarrollo lo que implica que
tiene que intentar compaginar el crecer
rápidamente al tiempo que se enfrenta a
todos estos problemas y amigos eso no va
a ser una tarea nada pero que nada fácil
fijaos por ejemplo cómo pintan las cosas
en apenas 30 años
pero no hay que irse tan lejos un
estudio elaborado a 353 empresas de
sichuan una de las provincias chinas más
pobladas ha arrojado el asombroso dato
de que casi el 58 por ciento de las
empresas tienen problemas para cubrir
posiciones vacantes por la escasez de
trabajadores
tal vez por todo esto no debería
extrañarnos que a día de hoy china sea
ya el líder mundial en robotización
industrial actualmente tiene más de
150.000 robots industriales en servicios
aproximadamente el 36 por ciento de
todos los robots industriales del mundo
[Música]
de esta manera el régimen de pekín
espera multiplicar la productividad de
los trabajadores o sea mantener o
incrementar la producción con menos
trabajadores para que se pueda mantener
un buen nivel de vida para la gente y
ojo porque no es el único país que ven
los robots su vía de escape al problema
demográfico
es exactamente la misma vía de escape
que persiguen en corea del sur-japón y
en prácticamente todos los países
desarrollados ante semejante
envejecimiento solo un crecimiento muy
fuerte de la productividad puede paliar
las graves consecuencias que puede tener
desde el punto de vista económico y
social
pero amigos la pregunta que nos podemos
hacer llegados a este punto es pero más
allá de los robots tiene este problema
la solución desde alguna perspectiva
demográfica que quiere hacer exactamente
el gobierno chino atentos
[Música]
cuando el daño está hecho
cuando el daño está hecho pues dar
marcha atrás resulta complicado tanto
dos años de ingeniería social han hecho
que la población china sea apática a
formar una familia y no sólo eso la
propia especialización productiva del
país pues tampoco invita a ello
veréis me explico china ha crecido muy
rápido durante las últimas décadas pero
sigue manteniendo niveles de
productividad relativamente reducidos
que eso implica que el país
especializado en competir en costes
laborales por ahora en industrias muy
intensivas en mano de obra
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea la
productividad por empleado y ahora en
eeuu es casi cinco veces más alta es
decir que lo que produce un
norteamericano por ahora es el
equivalente a lo que producen cinco
chinos esto implica que las jornadas de
12 o más horas no sean algo extraño
chinas requiere cambiar su modelo de
desarrollo económico pasando de la
producción intensiva en mano de obra y
de baja calidad en los productos a la
producción de bienes de alta calidad
don't know you director adjunto del
institute for chain and global
development de la facultad de economía y
negocios de la universidad de hong kong
el caso es que con semejante programa
profesional lo de tener hijos no parece
una misión sencilla no os parece
[Música]
pues amigos en cierto modo estos dos
elementos es decir la cultura gestada
con el paso de los años y la estructura
laboral están haciendo que el cambio de
la política del hijo único pues no sirva
de mucho o mejor dicho no nos sirva para
nada y eso eso es lo que explica cosas
como estas
[Música]
son ya varias provincias chinas las que
están restringiendo el aborto cuando
hasta hace poco tiempo lo promocionaba
algunas incluso han implementado la
necesidad de la firma de tres doctores
para poder abortar además también se
están empezando a implementar obstáculos
para divorciarse
será capaz del gobierno chino de obligar
a las familias a tener más hijos tal vez
establezcan privilegios ligados al
número de hijos o restrinjan el acceso a
servicios públicos o empleos si no se
cumple con la condición de tener al
menos dos hijos
[Música]
pues ojo porque de eso es precisamente
de lo que se está empezando a hablar
para combatir un tema que puede lastrar
no solo desarrollo económico sino
también las ambiciones geopolíticas de
china
[Música]
pero amigos llegados a este punto turno
para ti defenderías que el gobierno te
obliga a tener más hijos qué crees que
se puede hacer al respecto déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]